I was asked to talk spend 10 minutes to
talk about
so nany criminalization advocacy which
is
I think primarily there I'm focusing on
the work of the positive justice project
because it really is as far as I know
the only national organized attempt to
bring in people from a variety of this
disciplines to address the issue of
criminalization in the US it was
launched a little over a year ago we are
have seven different working groups
focusing on all of those areas from
federal advocacy and state advocacy to
specifically public health and legal
issues and research and we have quite a
few members the were I'm just going to
summarize some of the things that this
group has been working on because we do
through the members of the positive
justice project probably have our
fingers in most of what's happening
around the country on this some of our
work led to the national association of
State and territorial aids directors
issuing a excellent I think statement on
opposing criminalization or raising the
issues of whether of the public health
merits of not revisiting that issue the
president's advisory council on HIV and
AIDS had agreed after some advocacy to
identify it as a priority recently to
the administration we're working with
the Department of Justice and the CDC
some of that we can I can talk about if
anybody's interested some of that is
kind of in the works and congresswoman
barbara Lee released in September a bill
to address criminalization through both
directing federal agencies to do a very
broad-based review of a variety of
different constituencies to make
recommendations and best practices and
then to monitor how that happens in the
states and also provide some funding
incentives to get states to follow us
through so
has actually happened over the last year
at that level and it really in my
experience doesn't happen unless you are
involve a broad range of organizations
and allow lots of people to get involved
and visibly involved beyond your own
organization we also are doing a lot at
the state level we're holding we we
target places where there's a lot of
activity and are starting kind of at the
community level because what we found
and what I think many of the people in
this room know is that there is what
initially feels like almost invincible
ignorance at every level from the bottom
to the top about not only what the what
HIV criminalization laws are and their
impact but on the actual reason rest of
transmission and what the impact of
actually living with HIV is there has
been activity in a number of states
which I didn't include here most of it
not good and some of it which is okay is
worrisome because I again if if
policymakers aren't educated if you
don't if there isn't a starting basis of
understanding the likelihood that you're
going to get a good outcome i think is
questionable so we're doing a lot of
public education I wanted to talk just
identify some of the arguments that
we're using and that seemed to get when
Ivy traction people actually wake up and
listen and it seems to move people along
and some of this is reflected in the
draft bill that came out of
congresswoman barbara Lee's office it
really does reflect the points that they
felt had traction and and there were a
variety of things that we threw against
the wall and those and that bill
actually represents a lot of what's
stuck and they think will stick it's
posted on our website
we if anybody's interested we can talk
about it later but some of the things
that are clear is that we have to
address that the laws are based on
extraordinary ignorance about the risk
of transmission and how you can get
infected many bills as you as you know
and laws assume that spitting and biting
is a route of transmission and that any
sexual contact regardless of the type
whether we're talking about oral sex or
receptive anal sex poses the equivalent
risk it needs to be criminalized the and
I think the next point is one that I
want to highlight because this is the
point that really gets state and federal
policymakers to listen when you argue
that there are policies that are
directly undermining the money that they
are spending to encourage people to get
tested and to disclose their HIV status
because the consequences of doing those
things are the primary of this basis are
the primary requirements for being
prosecuted so that's some as folks like
Carol and other people in this room know
we don't have much information there are
a lot of assertions that it has an
impact on people's willingness to test
anecdotally when people know what might
happen that appears that it may be true
but we can't actually say that because
we don't know that it's true the lack of
proportionality a lot of folks will
thank yes you should anybody who has HIV
has the primary ultimate sole
responsibility to disclose and protect
people from infection what many people
don't know is what happens if the person
who's actually prosecuted that the fact
that it can result in in decades long
sentences
and in it also appears again anecdotally
another area we need research that some
of the isms that have been outlawed
through other measures prohibiting
discrimination on the basis of race and
disability get acted out one through the
acceptability of criminalization laws
these are just some of the these are
some of the some of the information
things like that are pulled out from
some of the stuff we give to both
community people policy makers it's all
adopted based on who it is we're
speaking to but getting folks to
understand what the actual risks are of
transmission in a single sexual contact
and and understanding that if we all
limited our sex lives to blow jobs there
wouldn't be an HIV epidemic and we
should stop pretending them that that's
not true and then and then this isn't
the kind of thing that illustrates that
the disparity and sentence is that it is
actually if you want to kill somebody
you you have a far more narrow window of
penile meeting the penal system excuse
me vulnerability if you run somebody
over with a car that if you and then if
you have sex to them while HIV positive
and these are just a couple of the
states that illustrate that point but
there are many more and I think when
people actually see that okay I could
get in a car run them over and kill them
and I'll get six months whereas if I
have sex with him and give him a [ __ ]
I could spend 15 years in prison they
they begin to see okay there's something
that going on here that is not entirely
rational